rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
on a eu une ère en Europe médiévale
chrétienne
dans laquelle la philosophie était une
sorte de servante de la religion c'est à
dire que le raisonnement était mis au
service de la foi et là on peut voir ça
déjà comme une première séparation
c'est-à-dire la foi donc la foi c'est le
cœur on parlera de Pascal par la suite
lorsqu'il disait que le cœur a ses
raisons que la raison ignore faite le
cœur chez Pascal c'est la foi mais la
foi dans une acception très large bien
sûr donc on a cette idée déjà d'une
première dichotomie entre la raison et
la foi et puis finalement l'histoire est
en scalée elle a abouti à une scission
entre la raison et la foi et là c'est
l'entrée dans la modernité c'est la
philosophie des Lumières c'est le
rationalisme le rationalisme
philosophiquement s'est construit en
opposition à la religion en opposition à
la fois en l'occurrence à la fois
chrétienne catholique et la phrase de
Voltaire écrasons l'infâme c'est
effectivement écraser le dogmatisme et
le fanatisme mais c'est aussi écraser ce
qui le rend possible à savoir
l'irrationalité donc le siècle des
Lumières la lumière c'est la métaphore
de la connaissance qui a donné être
clairvoyant qui a donné être lucide la
référence à la lumière c'est à dire les
lumières de la raison et donc c'est
comme si finalement le divorce avait été
prononcé et que la raison n'avait plus
voulu entendre parler de la foi la foi
devenait finalement le vers dans le
fruit le poison et il fallait absolument
s'en détourner d'autant que ça avait été
à la religion a été vectrice de guerre
de conflits donc on associe aussi à la
violence et aux fanatisme
je dirais que le XIXe siècle a été
vraiment le siècle de la science poussée
à son extrémité puisque non seulement
les découvertes dans le champ des
sciences physiques sur ce naturel les
progrès ont été considérables et en plus
on a vu ce développer en parallèle de
nouvelles disciplines scientifiques et
on est entré dans l'ère des sciences
humaines d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce
que comme s'il pouvait avoir des
sciences inhumaines mais en tout cas les
sciences humaines c'est à dire les
sciences sociales pour le dire vite ou
les sciences de l'esprit si on parle de
la psychologie c'était de vouloir
appliquer à l'être humain
des critères d'analyse qui sont ceux
qu'on appliquait à la matière inerte
donc on va analyser l'homme son esprit
son comportement via la sociologie comme
si finalement il était un pur corps
physique et d'ailleurs quand je dis ça
c'est pas une exagération de ma part
parce que on trouve dans certains textes
dès le 17e et le 18e siècle des
analogies qui sont faites par beaucoup
d'auteurs entre la la physique de la
matière puisque c'est presque c'est un
pléonasme mais aussi la physique sociale
la physique sociale c'est considérer que
les individus dans une société sont un
petit peu comme des comme des
micro-organismes et que on ne peut
comprendre finalement l'individu que si
on comprend le tout auquel il participe
il y avait cette approche là de
comprendre la société comme un organisme
mais moi ce que je remarque c'est que
même si je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant et sous certains aspects
j'adhère à cette méthodologie mais sous
un autre aspect je suis embêté
parce que je me dis qu'il y a quand même
dans l'être humain quelque chose qui ne
peut pas réduire à un simple corps
physique alors certains appelleraient ça
l'imprévisibilité mais d'autres
répondrai que la prévisibilité ce n'est
rien d'autre que le prévisible non connu
ce n'est rien d'autre comme des Espinoza
que l'ignorance des causes qui nous
détermine je j'admets cette objection
mais il me semble malgré tout qu'il y a
dans le monde humain des choses qui
échappent à la rationalisation
scientifique en tout cas
nos moyens de compréhension ne sont pas
encore tels qu'on puisse établir une
équivalence entre l'être humain et la
matière inerte
si nous étions omniscions on se rendrait
compte de tous les facteurs qui nous
échappent et là actuellement par exemple
je m'intéresse à la sociologie et à
Pierre Bourdieu et Pierre Bourdieu
c'était un déterministe social qui
disait que finalement on était le
produit de du conditionnement social et
de nos origines sociales
c'est à dire que bon la liberté n'existe
pas
il a pas tort statistiquement parlant on
retrouve effectivement un phénomène de
reproduction sociale donc se
déterminisme pour moi il n'est pas
inventé en revanche il existe ce qu'on
appelle des exceptions et ces exceptions
sont la preuve qui nous manque des
paramètres parce que dans le monde
physique les exceptions je veux dire si
je prends mon verre et que je le fais
que je lâche par terre il va tomber non
pas dans 99% des cas mais dans 100% des
cas moi ce 1% même s'il est pas grand
chose j'y tiens parce que c'est ce 1% de
non perçu
qui fait toute la différence entre
l'inertes et le vivant entre le matériel
et le conscient et la raison pour
laquelle je ne peux pas me définir
méthodologiquement et philosophiquement
comme un pur matérialiste
je reviens trois secondes sur le
déterminisme c'est une théorie selon
laquelle chaque événement est déterminé
par les événements passés par exemple ma
mère était fascinée par les artistes mon
père jouait de la guitare et chantait et
bien je suis devenu musicien guitariste
et chanteur pour plaire à ma mère ça
c'est le déterminisme selon ma psy et le
déterminisme de Bourdieu évoque le
capital économique le capital culturel
le capital social et symbolique qui vont
déterminer votre capacité à trouver
votre place dans la société en gros plus
vous avez d'argent plus vous avez de
relations plus vous avez accès à la
culture tout cela a des degrés divers et
bien plus vous pouvez vous en sortir
dans la vie
et donc je voudrais pas parler à la
place de Pierre Bourdieu qui de toute
façon n'est plus là pour objectif mais
quelque chose me dit qu'il répondrait à
Charles que même les exceptions sont
déterminées
[Musique]
je pense qu'il a raison simplement je
doute de la capacité humaine à lever le
voile sur ce déterminisme là
c'est à dire que il y a une complexité
telle qui fait que on entre pour moi
dans un autre ordre
c'est à dire que la complexité humaine
si on pouvait la mesurer serait
incommensurable en terme tu sais de de
micro mouvement de la conscience serait
incommensurable avec tout ce qu'on est
capable de mesurer dans les corps
purement physique
et il y a pas besoin de recourir à une
théorie de l'âme pour défendre cette
idée
si par exemple on part du principe que
la pensée c'est le pur produit de
l'activité cérébrale et neuronale
prononce cette hypothèse ça ne veut pas
dire pour autant qu'on est capable de
mesurer chaque micro mouvement de la
conscience parce que c'est infiniment
complexe et s'amusant d'ailleurs que la
physique quantique qui soit la
continuité de la physique classique on
arrive évidemment à une conclusion
similaire qui est de dire bah un certain
niveau d'infiniment petit on comprend
plus alors on comprend plus on comprend
plus ou moins moi en tant que spectateur
de ça je j'ai pas la prétention de
comprendre mais en revanche je vois
qu'il y a une incompréhension de ceux
qui sont censés comprendre des
scientifiques
qui essaye de comprendre et qui par
moments ont l'air de dire que notre
référentiel causal notre référentiel
logique ne s'applique plus et je me dis
tiens là pour le coup c'est moi qui
établirai le parallèle en disant ben
tiens vous avez voulu appliquer les
outils de la physique à l'être humain et
bien on voit que la physique finalement
elle est plus sûre elle-même du
comportement de la matière alors
imaginez ce qui doit en être pour les
êtres conscients je vais repartir sur ce
que tu disais qui me paraît très
intéressant sur la question de
l'observateur qui modifie la perception
et la mesure du corps c'est vrai que si
on s'amuse à faire l'analogie avec
l'être humain quand on est observé ou
plus généralement quand on est
au milieu d'autres individus c'est à
dire qu'on se sait vu on se sait
regarder
on est plus tout à fait soi-même on
devient une représentation de soi-même
et je fais souvent cette cette
distinction entre l'être et la
représentation entre l'être et le
paraître finalement vivre en société
c'est vivre en représentation ça veut
pas dire faire semblant ça veut même pas
dire se surveiller ça veut dire avoir
intégré une mécanique dans laquelle ce
sachant observer on va adopter soi-même
inconsciemment le plus souvent une sorte
d'habitus pour reprendre un terme de
Bourdieu
qui va correspondre à l'image qu'on veut
renvoyer de soi
et quelque part c'est nécessaire dire
Freud de disait bien et là-dessus je le
rejoins que il y a dans l'homme des
tendances qu'on est obligé de réprimer
pour pouvoir vivre en société et lui
d'ailleurs en fait l'origine de la
névrose c'est à dire d'un malaise et je
veux bien le croire et pour pour filer
la métaphore avec la physique quantique
quand on se sait observer et juger on
veut se rendre
identique à l'identité qu'on s'est
construite de soi on veut se rendre
cohérent avec cette identité là c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs qu'on va très
souvent se positionner sur les choses de
manière assez nette assez franche quand
on discute avec les autres là où notre
vraie nature finalement
serait beaucoup plus incertaine
dire quand on est tout seul chez soi ou
dans un endroit désertique
on se pose plus la question de notre
identité on ne se pose plus la question
de savoir si il faut se définir de tel
ou telle façon s'il faut argumenter
telle ou telle opinion qu'on a on se
pose pas la question on a le droit dans
ces moments-là à ne pas savoir qui l'on
est à douter à hésiter à fluctuer et
c'est seulement quand on est face à
quelqu'un que là on se sent le devoir de
se solidifier
intellectuellement psychologiquement et
mentalement pour être c'est à dire que
il est là le paradoxe c'est finalement
quand on cherche à être qu'on paraît et
c'est quand on oublie l'être qu'on est
et c'est pour ça moi je trouve ça
vraiment fascinant c'est la nature de ce
parallèle qu'on peut établir entre la
physique quantique et puis le
comportement de la conscience humaine
[Musique]